This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. What we're talking about today is very near and dear to my heart. You know, I wouldn't say it's my favorite thing to talk about because it's not a very pleasant topic, but it's something that really, I think, strums on my heartstrings. It really follows me around for long stretches of time. And it's something that I have begun to feel very at peace with. And that thing is loneliness. Loneliness is something that all of us in our 20s are going to experience. If you're not experiencing it now, it is coming for you. It's going to be around the corner.
but what does it actually mean to feel lonely during a time of your life that everybody will quickly tell you are the best years of your life. Everyone's going to say your 20s away should be most social, you'd have the most fun, you should be meeting your forever friends. But what if that is not your experience? Where do we find ourselves? How do we cope? This is actually an experience I've seen on the rise, friends, listeners, strangers,
asking me, why do I feel so lonely? Why do I feel so lonely despite having people around me, despite being young and carefree, despite feeling like I'm doing everything that I can to build community? And I have an answer for you. It's what I like to call the loneliest chapter of your 20s. This is a specific period that we all go through, the loneliest chapter, where regardless of how many relationships and friends we have, how many hours we spend socializing, how often we are surrounded with others, we still feel inexplicably lonely and emotionally isolated, not necessarily physically isolated, but like we are kind of an island within it all. And this lonely chapter, it's going to hit us all at some stage.
I actually think it's a rite of passage. I think it's a really important transition and milestone. And, you know, it feels really hard to explain, especially when you're in it. But afterwards, you kind of end up realizing that this was something that you had to go through. Perhaps, you know, you had to go through it because you were outgrowing people and we needed to speed up that process. Maybe because you're going through a major life change and you need more time to reflect on your own experiences and your own emotions. maybe you've just seen your broader social circle shrink and you need to kind of realize that it's time to maybe move on from those friends, make new friends, move into this new chapter.
I don't know what it is. I can't speak to what you're going through personally, but I do think that it's unavoidable and I think that it's actually quite necessary for us to experience this kind of sacred solitude early on in our lives in our 20s or this shedding of relationships. so that we can truly know what fills our cup. We can truly fall in love with our own company. We can know that solitude is not scary. It's sacred and we can grow through it.
And actually, by going through this lonely period, we end up coming out more socially and connected than ever. And I'm going to explain why that is. So this is what we're talking about today. What is the loneliest chapter of our 20s? Why might you be finding yourself there right now? why is it completely normal, but more importantly, why is it really valuable not to run from this loneliness and fill up your time with empty relationships and with distractions and with random people?
And instead, invest in the relationship you have with yourself. That is the longest relationship you are ever going to have. There is no relationship that will outlive the relationship you have with yourself. So let's talk about when loneliness factors in to this equation. Let's find out together without. further ado, I want to explain exactly what is going on if you find yourself in this period, in this chapter right now. Let's get into it. A few years back I came across this like spirituality phrase called the dark night of the soul and it just stuck with me. The concept of like the
dark night of the soul, it originated in in Spain, I think back in like the 16th century. If I've got my history right. And it's basically used to describe a really painful period in your life, a crisis that completely transforms you. It creates a complete shift and how you see the world, how you see yourself, your values, the meaning that you apply to experiences. And it actually doesn't need to be triggered by anything. It's more of an unconscious, or not even unconscious, it's more of an ego death, a rethinking of who you are. Now, some philosophers would tell you that they actually believe it's necessary to grow through this dark night in order to really understand yourself and your life. And if you don't go through that, you never actually gain self-actualization,
clarity, and true fulfillment. Now, I think that the loneliest chapter of our 20s does the same thing, but instead of being for our perspective and our identity, it's for our relationships. And you do need to go through this in order to deepen how you inevitably connect with people and what you see is important. So what does this? chapter look like? What is it kind of, what are the symptoms or the signs that you're going through this? Well, I think loneliness above or else, but not just loneliness because of a lack of physical relationships, like a lack of people around you. You know, it's very natural to feel lonely if you are struggling with any friendship, you know, if you actually just don't have friends.
But I also think it's a sense of boredom in your preexisting friendships, almost like an apathy towards wanting to hang out with them is a great desire to withdraw away or to not feel like you're fulfilled by your current relationships. There also may be like a heightened level of self-criticism feeling like you don't deserve the level and the depth of the relationships that you crave, a sense of restlessness, like, oh my God, I need to be making new friends, I feel so lost, I feel so aimless, and also some existential reflection. Being around people is definitely one of the best distractions from looking straight at our thoughts. And so when being around other people is not available as a distraction, when it's not doing its job anymore, all those thoughts and feelings that we
have unintentionally suppressed become very loud. It's really common, you know, for people to experience this when they move to a new city, a new country, when they go through a breakup, when they have their first child, you're going through a transition that disconnects you. And that's when you really enter the lonely chapter. The other big indicator for me is it feels like you're writing what I like to call the friendship roller coaster. Now, we have spoken about this on the podcast before, but this is a term that I originated. And it basically describes how at one moment you might feel incredibly fulfilled and happy and
delighted by your friendships. The next moment you're at, you know, the bottom of the roller coaster. You're constantly feeling miserable about your friendships. You feel at a low point. and then you're back at the top again and it's exhilarating and it's anxiety inducing and it's stressful but nothing is changing right you're still in the same vehicle you're still strapped into the same spot the people in the roller coaster with you have not changed but it's the path that you're taking and it really does feel like at one moment you have so many friends and then literally the next day
nothing's changed and it feels like you have none and that is I think really indicative of this lonely chapter it's indicative that something needs to change Sometimes I think it also comes on slowly, right? You might wake up one day and realize that your level of socialization, how often you see people, the amount of quality time you have with people has declined. It could have been a rapid descent, especially if there was a really major life change for you, or it could be gradual. And I like to give the analogy of the frog in boiling water.
So if you don't know this analogy, it's kind of a sad. one, but essentially if you put a frog in a big, what's it called, a pot, a big pot of water and you put it over the stove and you start to slowly boil the water, the frog actually will not jump out and it will end up being burned alive. Whereas if you dump a frog into a pot of boiling water, it will immediately jump out. This can go with friendships. You might slowly see that, you know one friend dropped off one friend moved you know one friend you don't talk to as much one friend got a boyfriend so you don't talk to her as much another friend you know you stopped working with them so it's not a daily interaction and it's kind of happening one by one the water is slowly boiling
and then one day you just kind of realized like oh this is who i was two years ago this is who i am now and there was a huge difference in a huge distance in who I see, who I am, how fulfilled I feel. I was talking to my friend Sarah about this the other day and how when she first moved to Sydney, her social calendar was just, oh my gosh, so intense. And she is still a relatively social person, but she was talking about how she would pack a bag for Friday and she would go and stay with friends on Friday and she would have, like, her day was split into, I think, like five sections, four or five sections.
So she had a pre-morning, which was like five till nine. Then she had a normal morning, which was like 10 to 12. And she had like afternoon, which was like one to three. Then she had like dinner time. And then she had like the evening slot. And she would see a new group of people or she would see people in every single block of time. Every single one of those blocks would be full for the whole weekend. And she was like, I just don't do that anymore.
And she was like, I don't realize, I didn't realize when it happened. but I kind of like woke up and like that just wasn't my life. And I had that same experience where I felt like I had this awakening where I was like, wow, I just don't socialize the way I used to. Something needs to change because I'm feeling quite lonely. This is going to sound ridiculous, but the thing that triggered it for me was Brat Girl Summer. Yes, the Charlie X, EX album and all the stuff that came along with that, I, that, I don't know what it was, but it reminded me of like who I perhaps was maybe four or five years ago and how I wasn't her anymore.
And it really made me take a real good look at my friendships and be like, huh, I've kind of been coasting on relate, on the backs of relationships that I've had for years without making new friends I since have. But for a for a long time, you know, I, I was just slowly adjusting to a way of life that actually felt in. inherently lonely and I felt like I was very displaced in the reality that I've created. So why does this actually happen? What would, you know, developmental psychologists tell us about this, tell us about this transition or this huge drop? Well, what creates this experience is actually two parallel experiences. The first is the loss of old friends and the difficulty in maintaining those relationships
at the same level within the changing circumstances of our 20s. And the second is difficulty in making new friends, not necessarily replacing those old friends, but just creating that same sense of belonging with new people in a similar way to the people that we previously had in our lives. Where can we find those environments and those spaces where we actually feel like we belong? So I'm going to begin by focusing on that first experience,
the loss of old friends, even if they're not necessarily out of your life, we do tend to notice the further we get into this decade, a distance. And I think that can be explained by three things that typically occurred during this period of life. First, we have splintering paths. You know, if you grew up with a group of people at the same time, you're the same age, you're going through the same experiences at the same time. So, you know, you are in primary school, you're in high school, you're going after college, off to university, you're working as part-time jobs together, you have all this time together. The experiences are very parallel. You could spend the ages of like two to like 22 in the exact same environment doing the exact same thing as someone else.
Then things splinter and you no longer have those parallel experiences in the parallel environments. You no longer have the convenience of seeing others at school or seeing others at a part-time job or seeing others, you know, starting with each other at university, there is no longer the ease and the convenience of maintaining a long-term friendship with someone who you've been really close to for a whole lot of time. This can also be precipitated by a big life change. You know, people do move, people have children, people experience a whole crazy, different amalgamation of life experiences.
They're not all going to be the same. So sometimes if someone's priorities and complete path in life is suddenly directed, we can't always keep up and the relationship falls by the wayside. Finally, and this is a huge one, especially in our, I would say mid to late 20s, is that we get life partners and we get partners. A lot of us start to take dating a lot more seriously. It's a big transition, I would say, or a big distinction between people who are in emerging adulthood. versus full-blown adulthood, it's the prioritization of partnership. So I say this a lot actually, and this is a very deep belief of mine. I think that your friends are the most important relationship between like 18 and 26,
but then after 26, about 50% of us start, or a large majority of us really start, you know, putting our partner as the most important relationship until, you know, we have kids. So that is how I see like our relationship priorities changing over the course of our life. If you're in your 20s, you might be smack bang in the middle of that transition. The transition towards partnership. And if you don't have a partner, but your friends do, it can feel like you're left out. It's interesting because according to research done by the University of Kansas, we lose an average of two friends per year in our mid to late 20s. And that carries on into our 30s.
I think it's a combination of all these factors, of all these different lifestyle shifts and changes and environments and situations and contexts and blah, blah, blah, that all combine to make friendship during this decade a lot harder. Now, when it comes to making new friends, we've already spoken about this, but you know, you're no longer in environments that make friendship convenient and that are effortlessly social. The number one way that people make new friends in adulthood is through work. Even that's not effortly social. It's just that you're close by to someone and you're in the trenches together so it's easy to form a relationship. Those environments, you've got to remember when we were kids and when we were teenagers
and when we were in our early 20s, there are a lot more of those environments available to us. Here's another really interesting insight. the most valuable factor for predicting whether a friendship will take place between two people, according to researchers, this is the number one factor that they cite. It's familiarity. Familiarity followed by similarity and proximity. But essentially, what they will say to you is that if you want new connections and you want new friendships, the more familiar you are with someone, the more bonded you feel.
And what does familiarity require above or else? it's time it's time something that we have less and less of the older we get and the more our like day is split into quadrants and pieces and quadruplets and you know everything just everyone wants a peace we have less time devoted to friendships but time is the crucial element geoffrey hall he's an expert in the psychology of friendship and he studied 450 individuals over the course of i think six months to a year and he found that it took about 45 hours of being in the presence of another person's company for you to consider that they are no longer an acquaintance but a friend. To move from casual friend to a meaningful
friendship took 50 hours over a three-month period. And to move into the inner close friendship circle, it took another 100 hours. When we were younger, we had that time to invest in friendship, shared experiences, core memories. But now, that time is filled with work, chores, just being tired. I was also speaking to a friend about this the other day, about how if you move cities or you move countries, people often have their established social circles. It's very hard to kind of find your way in. So if you are the expat, the new person in town, you're also going to, I think, particularly struggle. it's interesting because I'm seeing a lot of friends of mine and a lot of people that I knew from from uni and high school or moving to London or moving to Europe or New Zealand or the US
and they all end up finding each other again because they already have that pre-established sense of familiarity. So all as this goes to say if you're experiencing this period of riding the friendship roller coaster, if you are entering or in the midst of the loneliest chapter of your 20s, you are not alone. There is a whole developmental transitionary shift occurring in your life that is meaning that your day and your weeks and your months feel a lot more devoid of a sense of connection and a sense of being seen. We're all going to go through it at least once, maybe even more.
And I want to talk about where to next. Because what's really important to state is that this is actually a chapter. it is not permanent, it is not the rest of the story. And each of us will get through it. We are meant to get through it. There is something brighter on the other side. There is a reprioritization of certain relationships. There is a reaching out.
There is basically a conclusion to this chapter that I want you to find. It's something better that comes after it. So we are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of...
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice,
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It is my belief that I've stated many, many times, but I really wanted to come across that loneliness is actually not a curse, it's not a disease. It's more than that. It's an emotional cue. It is a physical cue.
It is an instinctual evolutionary cue. The same way that we experience hunger and thirst. as indicators that we are in need of something, we also experience loneliness. So take it as a sign from your body and a sign from your mind that it's simply just a need that is not fulfilled and that you do need to reach out. When you can also learn to be lonely and to turn that into a skill, you importantly are no longer reliant on relationships that don't fulfill you. because solitude is no longer a punishment.
The psychologist Carl Jung actually believed that solitude could almost be medicinal, could almost be healing, because it led to deep personal growth and self-actualization, especially in a world that is full, full of so many interactions, full of so much noise, so much stimulus, so much information coming in.
When do you get a time to yourself? When was the last time you had a time to yourself? where there wasn't something in front of your face or in your ears or, you know, something that you were interacting with. Solitude provides us with that space. Being alone gives you a chance to reflect on who you are, on your goals. It can bring greater self-awareness, personal development. You also gain something else really valuable, which is the ability to tolerate discomfort instead of going back to shit people. I see a lot of people who have, if I'm being honest, not great friends, really terrible friends who they actually don't like and who are quite awful to them.
But they continue to feel this really intense obligation and loyalty to them because they are the only thing that is between them and loneliness. And when you are scared of loneliness, you will accept, you know, the hell that you know over that uncertainty and over that discomfort. People try a lot of ways to get comfortable with discomfort. They try ice bars. They try extreme sports, extreme meditation. But who would have thought that just sitting with a lonely feeling is another way to reap the same rewards and to actually, and I'm going to say this, make you less attached to the people who don't deserve your attachment?
I'm not saying that it means that you need to withdraw or that you need to deliberately isolate yourself. I mean that when you have a sense of allegiance with your loneliness, when you feel like it is your friend rather than your enemy, you are not scared to choose the solitary, lonely path if it looks better than the one in which you have, you know, crap people around you, in which you are being mistreated in which you are being poorly treated, I guess, as well. So that was a really important lesson for me to learn, especially. I used to have a real intense fear of loneliness. I used to be really scared of what it would mean to be ostracized, be isolated. It made me feel unlovable to not be around people all the time. It made me feel like I was forgettable. And that led me to really stay
in situations that I didn't deserve to be in. But after a breakup, actually quite a few years ago, six years ago, I went and spent some time with my grandma. Now, my grandma has the most amazing, beautiful house in the Gold Coast, in Queensland, in Australia. It is like a jungle oasis next to the beach, up in the hills, we have our own gardens, we have, there's chickens, there's baby quails, there's kangaroos, there's bridges and streams. It's glorious. And I spent a long amount of time in that house just with her really healing after a breakup where I felt like I couldn't trust myself to continue to be around people who I knew were bad for me because I was constantly going to choose them over myself. And in that time, it was hard. It was really, really difficult.
身处我不该承受的境地。但在几年前，准确地说是六年前，经历了一次分手后，我去和我的奶奶住了一段时间。现在，我的奶奶在澳大利亚昆士兰州的黄金海岸拥有一栋极其惊艳、美丽的房子。它就像是一片藏在海滩旁山丘里的热带雨林绿洲，我们有自己的花园，有鸡、有小鹌鹑、有袋鼠，还有桥梁和小溪。这里简直美极了。我在那栋房子里和她度过了很长的一段时间，那是一次真正的心灵疗愈，起因是一次分手。当时我觉得自己无法再信任自己，无法继续和那些我知道对我有害的人在一起，因为我总是会选择他们而牺牲自我。在那段时间里，日子很难熬。真的非常、非常艰难。
But I rewired and I reprogrammed part of my personality and I would say my social blueprint that craved any form of a validation from being around people. any form of it, even when it came at my own expense. There is very little promised in life, but I think, yes, loneliness is one of those things, but the other thing is change. It can't stay like this forever. And so whilst you are in this lonely chapter, I really want you to get the most out of it that you can. As Carl Jung said, you know, it might actually be one of the biggest gifts to have a moment alone,
但我重新连接并重塑了我的一部分个性，也可以说是我的社交蓝图，改掉了那种渴望从人群中获得任何形式认可的心理。任何形式的认可，哪怕是以牺牲我自己的利益为代价。生活中的承诺寥寥无几，但我认为，孤独确实是其中之一，而另一个就是改变。情况不可能永远这样下去。因此，既然你正处于这段孤独的篇章中，我真的希望你能从中收获尽可能多的价值。正如卡尔·扬格所说，独自呆上一会儿，其实可能是人生收到的最棒的礼物之一，
to have a moment where you're not scared to be alone. So this is how I want you to actually, I'm not going to say, say enjoy the moment, but receive the gift from the lonely moment. Firstly, acknowledge your feelings. Please don't bury them. You will feel terrible at times. It isn't comfortable because humans aren't meant to be alone forever. But the people who miss out on the lesson from this period are those who avoid ever feeling
去享受一个不用害怕孤独的时刻。所以，这是我希望你真正去做的，我不会说“去享受这个时刻”，而是去接收来自孤独时刻的礼物。首先，正视你的感受。请不要将它们掩藏起来。有时你会感觉糟糕透顶。这并不舒服，因为人类生来就不是为了永远孤独的。但是，那些错过了这一时期教训的人，正是那些总是刻意逃避这种感受的人。
that feeling at all. They do seek comfort in distraction. And that is a form of avoidance, which means that we actually continue to sustain. the unhealthy and fearful relationship we have with loneliness, which is a perfectly helpful human emotion. Psychologists and more importantly, researchers who study our unique emotional approaches to loneliness, they've actually found that people who view this emotion
他们试图在转移注意力中寻求慰藉。这其实是一种逃避，这意味着我们实际上在不断维持一种与孤独的不健康且充满恐惧的关系，而孤独其实是一种完全有益的人类情感。心理学家，更重要的是，那些研究我们对孤独独特情感处理方式的研究人员，他们实际上发现，那些将这种情感视为自我发现机遇而非急于逃避的人，
as an opportunity for self-discovery rather than something to escape from, they find a lot of meaning. It feels less like isolation and more like personal space, but they also become more clear and more focused on their goals. Here's another amazing benefit for you, if you're going through this right now. According to a 2020 study that looked at our perceptions of loneliness and the interactions or the correlation with emotional intelligence amongst young adults, having a mature grasp on loneliness makes you more emotionally intelligent.
会从中找到很多意义。这种感觉与其说是被孤立，不如说是拥有个人空间，同时他们也会变得更加清晰，更加专注于自己的目标。如果你现在也正经历这一切，这里还有一个给你带来的惊人好处：根据2020年的一项研究，该研究探讨了我们对孤独的看法以及年轻人之间情感智力的互动或相关性，对孤独有成熟的理解能让你更具情商。
It means that your ability to name, identify, appropriately respond to your own emotions and then also identify those emotions in other people and have a successful response, make people feel like you relate to them and that you care about them, your ability to do that improves like no tomorrow. That is what we're gaining, despite what we feel like we're missing.
这意味着你能够命名、识别、恰当地回应自己的情绪，然后还能识别其他人的情绪并做出成功的回应，让人们觉得你对他们感同身受并且关心他们，你做到这一点的能力会突飞猛进。这就是我们的收获，尽管我们觉得自己似乎失去了很多。
We're actually gaining a more keen social and emotional ability. The second way that I think you can really help yourself through this period is to firstly take a social media detox, you know, I'm not trying to say that this loneliness is like the best thing ever and that you need to be happy about it all the time. It actually does still feel quite painful. So don't make that experience more painful than it has to be. Take a break, take a step back, disconnect from social media, rethink your relationship with it. And whether it is contributing to your fear of missing out and meaning that you are only focusing on your experiences in comparison to what others look like.
我们实际上获得了更敏锐的社交和情感能力。我认为你能真正帮助自己度过这段时期的第二个方法是，首先进行一次社交媒体排毒。你知道，我并不是想说这种孤独是什么绝佳的好事，也不是说你需要一直为此感到快乐。它其实依然会让人感到相当痛苦。所以，不要让这种经历变得比实际更痛苦。休息一下，退后一步，与社交媒体断开连接，重新审视你与它的关系。无论它是否助长了你的“错失恐惧症”（FOMO），导致你只关注自己的经历与别人看似光鲜的生活之间的对比，
I think that you'll find that the answer is yes. And when you have less opportunities to engage in that comparison, the joy comes back. Romanticize the experiences that you have on your own as well. I have a friend who does date nights with themselves. Once a month, they go to an Italian restaurant, they order a glass of wine and they bring their journal and they answer a series of five questions, you know, what am I proud of myself for? what do I want in the next month? What is something that I'm going through?
我想你会发现答案是肯定的。当你减少了进行这种比较的机会时，快乐就会回归。同时，将你独自一人的经历浪漫化。我有一个朋友，她会和自己进行“约会”。每个月一次，他们会去一家意大利餐厅，点一杯酒，带上日记本，回答一系列五个问题，比如：我为自己感到骄傲的是什么？我在接下来的一个月里想要什么？我正在经历什么？
How am I feeling like a genuine check-in? And they really look forward to this date with themselves once a month. I have another friend who does regular solo trips. Another friend who goes on daily walks in different neighborhoods. And that's like her alone time just for her. And she's like, it's like the best time of my day, which I love. Another friend of mine has a to-da list. And I actually have one of these as well.
我感觉如何？这就像是一次真诚的自我盘点。他们真的非常期待每月一次的与自己的约会。我还有另一个朋友，她经常进行独自旅行。另一个朋友喜欢在不同的街区进行日常漫步。那是她独属于自己的独处时间。她总是说：“这是我一天中最美好的时光。”我太喜欢这样了。我的另一个朋友有一个“待办大自然清单”。其实我也有这样一个清单。
It is like a folder in my phone, like an album, of things that I've experienced when I was on my own that only I got to enjoy in that moment. Something that I put in there the other day was like I saw these like, oh my God, this huge mass of bees like pollinating these poppies. And sometimes when you see beautiful things like that, your first inclination is to be like, oh my God, who can I show? Who can I tell? And I was like, wait, I am having this experience on my own. and that is actually really beautiful. So I'm just going to, obviously I've just shared it with you. So I get the irony and hypocrisy and what I'm about to say.
它就像是我手机里的一个文件夹，或者说相册，里面存着我独自一人时经历的事情，而那些时刻只有我一个人独享。前几天我放进去的一张照片是我看到这些，哦天哪，一大群蜜蜂在给这些罂粟花授粉。有时当你看到这样美丽的景色时，你的第一冲动可能是想：“天哪，我可以给谁看？我可以告诉谁？”然后我想：“等等，我正在独自体验这一切，这其实真的很美。”所以当然，我刚才已经把它分享给你们了。我明白我接下来要说的话有多么讽刺和虚伪。
But sometimes really appreciating that your own company and your own experience of something is worthwhile in itself means that you're no longer afraid to experience those things by yourself. You've got to see the romance in it. Sometimes that is the best mindset shift is to, instead of seeing like a danger or a torture is to be like, how can I make this beautiful and lovely and special? I start a new hobby as well. Now, this one is like, should have been number one at my list. I started a ceramics class, like almost four months ago now that I've continued to do.
但有时候，真正去欣赏你自己的陪伴以及你对某件事物的独特体验本身就是有价值的，这意味着你不再害怕独自去体验这些事情。你必须从中发现浪漫。有时候，最好的心态转变不是把它看作一种危险或折磨，而是去想：我该如何让这一切变得美丽、可爱而又特殊？我还培养了一个新爱好。现在，这个爱好本来应该排在我清单的第一位。我开始上陶瓷课，大约四个月前开始的，并且一直坚持到现在。
But the reason I did it was because I was like, every, you know, thing that I do for fun is with other people. And I'm feeling actually quite detached from myself. And so I know that when those other people aren't around, I'm going to feel very lonely. so I want to do something that is just for me and I signed up for this class. I think it was like $300, which a lot of money up front, but then it pays itself forward. And it has been one of the best things for my mental health and for my feelings of isolation during this time in my life. I've also made a lot of friends through it.
我之所以这么做，是因为我觉得我做的每一件为了好玩的事情都是和别人一起。而且我实际上开始觉得和自己有些疏离了。所以我知道，当那些人不在身边时，我会感到非常孤独。所以我想要做一些纯粹为了我自己的事情，于是我报名了这个课程。我想费用大概是300美元，前期是一大笔钱，但随后它会带来回报。这对我这段人生低谷期的心理健康以及缓解孤立感起到了极大的帮助。我也通过它交到了很多朋友。
It started off as a solo practice and has actually become something upon which I've built community. You know, I have a friend from Ireland who was doing the course with me. I've got like, you know, the woman who sits across from me, I'm not going to say their names because they might not want me talking about them on this podcast, but this woman who sits across for me is like 50. And last week she brought me in honey. And all of that came from not being afraid to do something alone, even if it felt lonely,
它最初是一个人的练习，但实际上已经演变成了一个让我建立社群的平台。你知道的，我有一个来自爱尔兰的朋友和我一起上这门课。还有坐在我对面的人，我就不透露他们的名字了，因为他们可能不想让我在播客里谈论他们。但坐在我对面的这位女士大约50岁了。上周她还带给我蜂蜜。这一切都源于不害怕独自做一件事，哪怕它感觉很孤独，
and finding that there were these other people who were doing the same thing, who were also looking for connection and we found it in each other. If it is the case that you're the root of your loneliest chapter and the root of your loneliness at this point is a deficit of good people, try and build a routine in which you will see the same people. So this is, you know, the ceramics course is one of those things where every Tuesday I know that I'm going to see these people and that we're forming a bond and that we feel like we belong together and we can share this experience.
并且发现还有其他人也在做同样的事情，他们也在寻找连接，我们在彼此身上找到了这种连接。如果你发现你孤独篇章的根源以及此时感到孤独的根源是缺乏优秀的同伴，那就试着建立一个能让你定期见到同一群人的日常规律。所以，这就是陶瓷课这样的活动，每个星期二我知道我都一定会见到这些人，我们正在建立一种纽带，我们觉得我们属于彼此，我们可以分享这段经历。
If you have opportunities to interact with the same people at the same time, like if you go to the same gym class every week, if you go to the same local cafes, you go to the same art class every week, you'll naturally create that familiarity and have that time investment that we can see is really important for building new friendships. We also have a full episode on making new friends in your 20s because gosh, is it not hard? And I'm totally in the same boat with you when it comes to this. So if you search that in Spotify or Apple, you will find it. And finally, don't neglect perfectly healthy friendships. I know that it can feel difficult when we're going through this lonely chapter to look around and be like, oh my God, I just feel miserable. No one understands me. I don't have
如果你有机会在同一时间与同一群人互动，比如你每周去上同一节健身课，去同一家本地咖啡馆，每周去上同一节艺术课，你就会自然而然地培养出这种熟悉感，并投入时间，正如我们所看到的，这对于建立新的友谊非常重要。我们还有一整集关于如何在20多岁结交新朋友的节目，因为天哪，这难道不难吗？在这个问题上，我和你们完全感同身受。所以如果你在Spotify或Apple上搜索一下，就能找到它。最后，不要忽视那些完全健康的友谊。我知道，当我们经历这段孤独的时期时，环顾四周并觉得“天哪，我太惨了，没有人理解我，我没有
the relationships that I want. Actually sit with yourself for 10 minutes. Maybe it's not the relationship, not the people, it's the type of relationship you have with them. So maybe they don't need to be completely blacked out, kicked out of your life. The relationship isn't over. It just needs to be redefined. So focus on those healthy friendships, focus on those people, even if you're not quite friends with them yet who you do really want in your life and who you really like and who you really enjoy and try and spend more time with them, put more energy into the good people, the kind people, the lovely people, the ones who make you feel that spark and that energy and that joy compared to relationships which are just continuing to fail you
我想要的那些关系”，可能会让人觉得很难受。其实，花10分钟和自己待在一起。也许问题不在于关系本身，不在于人，而在于你和他们之间的关系类型。所以也许他们并不需要被彻底拉黑、踢出你的生活。这段关系并没有结束，它只是需要被重新定义。所以，专注于那些健康的友谊，专注于那些人，即使你们现在还称不上真正的好朋友，但如果你确实希望他们出现在你的生活中，你真的很喜欢他们、很欣赏他们，那就试着花更多的时间和他们在一起，把更多的精力投入到那些优秀、善良、可爱、能给你带来火花、能量和快乐的人身上，而不是那些不断让你失望、
and leave you feeling quite worthless. My final reminder, to sum up this episode, this is normal. This is totally normal. And what it's going to allow you to do is reconnect with yourself. It's going to give you the motivation to make better friends, to be a better friend, to chase connection and good conversation. and I think it's also an important point for your future self to feel grateful for where they are at. And if that doesn't make sense, I just think that, you know, in five years time, three years time, two years time,
让你觉得自己毫无价值的关系。我最后的提醒，来总结这一集：这是正常的。这完全正常。它将让你做的事情是重新与自己建立连接。它会给你动力去结交更好的朋友，成为更好的朋友，去追求人际连接和美好的对话。我认为这也是为了让你未来的自己对他们所处的位置心存感激，这一点很重要。如果这听起来有些费解，我的意思是，在五年后、三年后、两年后，
after you have exited the loneliest chapter of your 20s, you are going to look back at where you are now, and you will be in a better place and you'll say, oh my God, I get why I needed to go through that, because there were all these new relationships and friendships waiting for me on the other side, waiting for me to discover them and waiting for me to discover the peace and the happiness in my solitude that has made me a better person in my relationships. So I hope this has been comforting. I hope this has taught you something. I hope you know that you are going to be okay and that new relationships will come into
在你走出了20岁最孤独的篇章之后，你回过头来看自己现在的位置，你会处于一个更好的状态，你会说：“天哪，我终于明白为什么我必须经历这一切了，因为所有这些新的关系和友谊都在另一端等着我，等着我去发现它们，等着我在独处中发现平静与快乐，这让我成为了一个在人际关系中更好的人。”所以我希望这能给你带来安慰。我希望这能教给你一些东西。我希望你知道你一切都会好起来的，新的关系会走进
your life. So unless you focus on the relationship you have with yourself first, until next time. If you enjoyed this episode, send it to a friend, send it to someone. who you really want to get to know, who needs to hear this, who, you know, you care about, who might be going through the same thing. Make sure that you are following along on either Apple Podcasts or Spotify. And if you are listening on Apple Podcasts, I do have a small request. If you could leave us a five-star review, that would be greatly appreciated.
你的生活。所以，除非你首先关注自己与自己的关系。直到下次。如果你喜欢这一集，请把它分享给朋友，分享给某位你真的很想去了解、需要听到这些、你所关心且可能正在经历同样事情的人。请确保在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上关注我们。如果你正在Apple Podcasts上收听，我有一个小小的请求。如果你能给我们留下一条五星好评，我们将不胜感激。
Make sure that you are also following us on Instagram, because if you have follow-ups this episode, if you want to vote on what episodes come out next, you want to see when we have live events when things are announced. That is where you'll get all of that information. And until next time, my lovely podlings, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself, especially during this lonely chapter. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
请确保也在Instagram上关注我们，因为如果你对这一集有后续疑问，如果你想投票决定接下来播出什么节目，想知道我们什么时候举办现场活动以及发布公告，你都可以在那里获取所有这些信息。直到下次，我可爱的听众朋友们，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，尤其是在这段孤独的时期。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好！欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
但你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“你捏造了这个特定的检测两次，对吧？”“我捏造了一次检测。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
我的脑洞大开了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
这就是IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方播出的《TWO%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。“我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。”我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。